so good morning and I hope everybody
will answer my questions with as much
volume as Anissa was able to get out of
you the second time so today I gave the
title your DNA sense or nonsense we're
going to talk about RNA as well as DNA
but we're gonna start out with DNA so
how many people know what DNA is okay as
somebody want to tell me what DNA is
what's DNA fantastic what does it do
okay
and is it an atom or is it a molecule
wow you guys are really smart but it's
an unusual molecule in that it's very
very long and very thin so you can think
of it as being like a piece of string
this would probably be equivalent to the
amount of DNA that we have in one of our
chromosomes if I we're doing spool the
entire piece of thread and there's lots
and lots and lots of it but it's pretty
skinny right and you probably all know
that it has four bases and that the code
for our proteins is in the sequence of
those four bases along the DNA strands
okay how many of you has seen DNA couple
people have seen DNA okay what I have
here for those of you who haven't is a
solution that's got some DNA at it do
you see a sort of gray color right but
do you see anything else okay and I'm
going to put a stirring rod in it and
I'm gonna stir it and sort of nothing
happens right now I'm going to add some
ethanol
carefully hope I can do this right be
very disappointing if it doesn't work
okay and I've kind of sort of measure it
out so I've got to put in twice as much
ethanol I'm at 200 so I've got to go up
to 600 so I'm gonna do this very
carefully
sorry it's taking so long here
okay so can some of the people who are
in the front row come up and tell me
what they see now come on okay sort of
looks like two layers right of something
that looks like sort of strands right
could people in the back see this at all
can you see that there are two layers
and that there's starting to be
something sort of coming out of the
layer okay so now I'm going to go in
with a stirring rod and do this and I
want other people from the front row to
come up and tell me what they're seeing
now so that all that fluffy stuff is
starting to get picked up on this rod
see it's like spaghetti exactly yeah
okay
and so what we're seeing here are the
long strands of DNA so can you all see
it now they're long strands of DNA here
okay so now you've all seen DNA and if
anybody wants to come up later I've got
more test tubes and more solution if you
want to do it yourself afterwards you
can all come up and do this and see the
DNA come out of solution okay
so let's get back to what we're going to
talk about so everybody already knows
what DNA is so let me talk a little bit
about me and my relationship to DNA you
guys learned about DNA in grade school
or in junior high school or maybe high
school when I was there DNA
doesn't even mentioned even though the
double-stranded structure of DNA that
you all probably know about the two
strands come apart and then serve as
templates for making additional strand
so that the information can be passed on
to the next generation you all know this
that had been discovered before I was in
high school but it was so new it hadn't
made it to any of the text books yet as
a matter of fact I went back and looked
at my high school biology book and it
had one sentence in it about DNA and you
were absolutely right except what my
sentence said was it is thought that
genes might be made of a substance
called DES oxy ribonucleic acid that was
the old term for deoxyribonucleic acid
and that was absolutely yet and I knew I
was interested in science so I majored
in science when I got to college and the
time I found out about DNA was like
eight or nine years after 1953 after the
discovery of the double-stranded
structure of DNA by Watson and Crick and
the way I found out about it was I
happened to get a job at MIT and went to
a lab that was in this new field of
molecular biology and they were of
course studying DNA and I remember when
I got there that I was and found out
about this that I was absolutely
fascinated because I'd known I was
interested in science I would thought
genetics were really interesting but I
didn't think that anybody would ever be
able to put molecules together with life
and when you saw that beautiful
double-stranded structure and saw how it
could come apart and replicate you knew
immediately that there was a possibility
so I got very excited but nonetheless I
decided that I should go to medical
school not go to graduate school and try
to study DNA and how
DNA worked and that was because after
high school I never had a woman
professor in science I worked in a
number of labs I never saw woman
professor at any other university but I
did know some women doctors so I decided
that I should go to medical school and
what changed my mind was that the summer
before I was about to go to medical
school I ended up working in the lab of
a very famous scientist named Joe gall
who at that point was at the University
of Minnesota and then spent most of his
year or most of his career here at Yale
in Klein tower right next door and for
the first time he gave me my own project
to work on
and I got so excited by doing my own
project instead of helping other people
through theirs which I'd done previously
that I decided I didn't really care
whether I would never get to be a
professor all I wanted to do was to make
the discoveries and have fun finding out
about how DNA and RNA worked so I went
off to graduate school and that was a
time when this field of molecular
biology which now you all know about was
really really new and the people in the
field thought that if you were going to
find out anything you had to start very
simple and this was actually a good
judgment at that time so they decided
that the only things that were worth
working on were bacteria little cells
that swim around and the viruses that
infect bacteria and as a matter of fact
the feeling was so strong that you had
to do simple work with simple systems
that people who are trying to work on
complicated cells like the ones that
come out of our bodies we're even sort
of scorned as wasting their time because
it was so complicated they would never
figure anything out so starting there
and looking at what's happened is
something I never could have imagined
would happen that we would know and you
guys know this right that we would know
the four billion base pairs of the human
genome in the sequence and how it
specifies many of the proteins or that
knowing about DNA would do things like
give rise to Diagnostics in medicine
therapies in medicine even DNA forensics
everybody knows about how DNA is used to
find out whether it was this person or
that person who was at a crime scene
that all was totally unimaginable when I
started or that there'd be a
multi-billion dollar biotech industry
making lots of money off this whole
field and of course it was a surprise
and I'll come back to this at the very
end that there were at that point that
there were no women in science and today
they're both women science professors
you've just seen two of them and even
women as presidents of universities so
that's changed a lot and I want to say a
little bit at the end about about women
in science so I've told you now about
where I started and now I want to go on
and talk about relating my title sensor
nonsense which is in our DNA back to
something about RNA and something called
Smurfs
which are little particles in cells that
are very important to the cell for
getting the information out of the DNA
so that it can be translated into
proteins
so let me go on here okay so I'm going
to tell you the story of Smurfs and this
is a sort of unusual story in science
because a lot of us think of scientists
is going in and making
discoveries and then somebody comes
along and figures out how to apply them
to medicine but this is a story where a
disease called lupus provided the
materials with which to find out about
the basic science so do any of you know
anybody that has this disease called
lupus a number of hands went up any of
the kids you do so this is a disease
that it's about right that a number of
people should know they're about one in
a thousand people in our population has
lupus it's more common in women than in
men its more common in blacks than in
whites there are a number of other
diseases that are related to lupus
they're all called autoimmune diseases
and I'll tell you why that is in just a
moment so the other diseases are things
like mixed connective tissue disease
dermatomyositis sometimes the arthritis
and scleroderma which got a lot of
publicity about ten years ago because
breast implants were tied up with
scleroderma and scleroderma it's
interesting is a disease where the sort
of outer surfaces of the skin get very
hardened and it's probably the disease
that Lot's wife in the Bible had when
she turned into a pillar of salt
very stiff we don't know that of course
but that's probably what was going on
okay so what's happening in people with
lupus or these other autoimmune diseases
so how many of you know about antibodies
lots of kids know about antibodies what
antibodies do over here antibodies you
want to say what do antibodies do right
there on the slide you can read it yeah
yeah when you get infected with a
bacteria or a virus
right great okay so antibodies are
something that your body your immune
system makes when it's exposed to
something foreign and that interaction
between the antibodies and the foreign
molecules clear them from your system so
that next time you won't get sick it's
exactly what you said right but
sometimes in some people and this is
what happens with lupus and these other
diseases something goes wrong with their
immune systems ability to tell the
difference between molecules that are in
your own cells and these molecules that
are in bacteria and viruses that are
foreign
and so what those people then make and
it's a rare disorder is antibodies
against their own cellular components
which are called Auto antibodies and
that's why these are known as autoimmune
diseases and what happens if you have
Auto antibodies let's think about it if
they're antibodies against your own
cellular components then let's say you
go out in the sunshine and you get a
sunburn that kills your cells or not a
lot but some of your skin cells and they
die and they dump their contents into
your blood so if you have Auto
antibodies then you get these
interactions between your antibodies
your Auto antibodies and your own
cellular components to form what are
called immune complexes and these things
build up in big networks sort of like we
saw with the DNA in your blood stream
and the reason that the disease is
called lupus is people get a red rash
and that's because a lot of these
complexes have deposited in the little
capillaries that are under the skin okay
the complex is also depositing the hair
follicles so people's hair falls out
they deposit in the joint so people
can't move very well they deposit
actually in all the internal organs
these are systemic diseases and very
very difficult to treat and a lot of
people end up succumbing to kidney
disease because the immune complexes
deposit preferentially in the kidneys
and those are actually antibodies
against DNA so so that's the next
question is what is it that in these
diseases people make auto antibodies
against and it turns out for reasons we
don't understand that there's some of
the most abundant and highly conserved
things inside cells okay how many of you
kids have heard DNA makes RNA and RNA
makes protein very large fraction of
who's here right okay so here's a
picture of DNA this is a strand of DNA
they're polymerase is moving along
making RNA so strands of RNA and those
are getting coated with ribosomes which
are the protein making machinery inside
the cells so here you're seeing DNA
makes RNA makes protein and in fact some
patients with lupus make antibodies
against ribosomes protein synthesis
factories many people with lupus make
antibodies against their own DNA and
that's what deposits and the kidneys and
causes the real problems but many also
make antibodies against snips no slurps
aren't in this picture because this is a
picture of what goes on in bacteria and
bacteria don't have snips but our cells
have streams so what are snips why do we
have them and this has to do with the
sense and the nonsense in our genes so
let me move on to how did how did I get
into this whole area
here we're looking at DNA right and
we're looking at the amount of DNA and
you can tell how much there is by you
know what a big pile of strands there
are there and after this very time when
everybody thought you had to be very
simple some molecular biologists started
thinking well we'd better start looking
at higher cells and most people said oh
they'll be just the same but some people
said maybe they'll be different and we
now know they're very different in terms
of our DNA so what this slide shows is
here's a virus and it has about 200
genes and that's the amount of DNA
here's a bacterium it has about 2,000
genes so does that look like about 10
times as much DNA yep this is a
mammalian cell a huge amount of DNA and
people used to think we had about a
hundred thousand genes do any of the
kids know how many genes we think we
have now but billions No
anybody know anybody else know we have
about probably about 27,000 genes anyhow
this amount of DNA was way more than
what we would need for twenty thousand
seven thousand genes about a thousand
times more and this was very puzzling to
people was also true that mammalian
cells made lots and lots of RNA copying
the DNA but that lots of that RNA got
degraded in ourselves and never turned
into a messenger RNA to make protein so
I got interested in trying to solve that
problem on a sabbatical and the project
didn't work so I gave up and did
something else and when I came back to
Yale everybody in my lab wanted to work
on this particular problem and what had
happened in the meanwhile was that it
had been discovered that our genes
really are different from the genes and
bacteria
in that they have pieces in them that
are the sense parts but in between are
nonsense bits and often the nonsense
bits are longer than the sense bits and
what our cells need to do that bacteria
don't need to do is something called
splicing they need to make cuts at the
ends of the sense bits and join them
back together to make a messenger RNA
that can make protein and that's
illustrated I think even better in this
slide where it says even though the
three-letter code remains and then
there's a bunch of gibberish that's the
intron and then we go back to the exon
that's the expressed part and another
intron of gibberish nonsense and then
back to the sense part so this is what
our genes look like they're sort of
genes and pieces they are separated by
these bits of nonsense so what this
meant is that ourselves in contrast to
bacterial cells have to have some
machinery in them right that's going to
recognize these junctions between the
nonsense
and the sense and cut precisely and join
everything back together so that you
could make a sense messenger RNA yeah
exactly
so here's the slide okay you were you
know which the sense parts are and
there's the nonsense and virtually all
of our genes not all of them but 99% of
our genes look like this okay so as I
mentioned people in my lab wanted to
work on this but we didn't really know
how to do this or what to do and then
came a piece of serendipity how many
kids know what serendipity means who
wants it there's a handoff way back
there
what serendipity look it's when
something happens that you weren't
expecting
it's not connected to anything but it
turns out to make a difference usually
and that serendipity was an article that
appeared in the journal Nature and it
mentioned patients with mctv and I told
you before that that was like lupus it
was one of these autoimmune diseases and
what I'd been trying to think about that
hadn't worked was the fact that there
might be particles in cells and that
these particles might have something to
do with how the cells got rid of the
nonsense and the minute that we saw this
article people had mentioned to me that
you know maybe there were patients that
made antibodies against what I was
trying to work on but I hadn't known who
to contact when this article came out I
was back at Yale and I had a MD PhD
student in my lab named Michael Lerner
I'll show you his picture later and I
said to Michael do you know anybody here
at Yale who might have patience with MCT
CTD and he said sure I'll go across the
street and see Harden who was the head
of the Rheumatology section in the
department of internal medicine and he
did that and came back and started to
work with these patients blood that had
the auto antibodies in them right away
and eventually what we figured out was
that these auto antibodies were directed
against cellular components that happen
to be snaps and what those are are
little particles that have RNA and
protein in them and those are the things
that recognize those junctions between
the sense and the nonsense and what they
then do is they get those two ends
together and arrange for the nonsense in
between to be cut out and the sense
parts to be joined back together and
here's a picture of this happening
here's the DNA again here's the RNA here
thus nerfs and other things at these
what are called splice sites the ends of
the nonsense
and you see these particles building up
here you see what's called a spliceosome
and here the whole nonsense bit the
intron is looped out and it's about to
get cut and rejoined and made shorter
and you've gotten rid of the nonsense
okay so that's what's going on in your
cells all the time has to happen
virtually any time a gene is turned on
it makes RNA but that RNA has got
introns in it and it's got to get
spliced by this process so let's think
about what that means okay so what it
means is that our cells have this extra
step in making proteins they make the
RNA but it's got nonsense in it and the
nonsense has to come out by the SERPs
finding the junctions and making a
spliceosome and then making a messenger
RNA so let me show you I think okay so
thinking about this and now moving
forward this was a number of years ago
what does this mean for our
understanding and what does it mean for
disease virtually all of our genes have
this exon intron exon structure sense
nonsense sense nonsense etc and what
that means is that they're different
ways of splicing the RNA coming off a
gene so that you can either make a
protein that has the red bit or a
protein that doesn't have the red bit
they're different proteins and turns out
that Drosophila has about the same
number of genes the little fruit fly as
we do but we do more of this stuff this
alternative splicing so we can get more
out of that same number of genes and
make more proteins and be more
complicated so that's important in terms
of understanding evolution the other
in terms of understanding disease there
are a lot of diseases where the splicing
process goes awry in a particular gene
and their diseases like cystic fibrosis
and spinal muscular atrophy muscular
dystrophy where people are now trying to
figure out how to correct the splicing
process in those genes and some progress
is being made because what you need to
do is get out of it something that can
actually a messenger RNA that can make
protein and I'm just coming up on the
end here this is a picture this is
Michael Lerner the MD PhD student that
started working with the antibodies here
we were conferring with said Altman in
the biology department here that day
about possible collaborative experiments
so there were a lot of people involved
and one of the really fun things about
doing science is that you get to work
with a lot of other people figuring out
how to do experiments that tell you how
things work and so what I want to end
with is to go back to my thesis adviser
Jim Watson who's shown there Watson and
Crick and here's the these were two
other graduate students who were in the
lab when I was there Mario kappa she is
at the university of utah he now has his
own nobel prize that's gary Gustin and i
want to tell you about Jim Watson's
advice for succeeding in science many of
you will know that he's quite an
eccentric person but he's also a very
honest person he always calls it exactly
like it is
and his first rule is to succeed in
science you have to avoid dumb people
okay what does this mean we all know
that if you go out say you're going out
to play tennis if you play tennis with
somebody who's worse than you are your
game probably isn't very good but if you
play tennis with somebody who's better
than you are then you usually play
better and that's what this means find
the smartest people you can and
associate with them to make a huge
success the scientist has to be prepared
to get into deep trouble and what that
means is you have to take on really
challenging problems like Michael Lerner
did when you use lupus auto antibodies
to discover stirrups so you have to be
prepared to do something challenging
this is actually about mentors when if
you're doing challenging things and
things get difficult it's very important
to have friends and mentors who will
help you figure out how to get out of
those difficult situations never do
anything that bores you well we all know
if you're bored you're not very
interested you're not doing your best so
you shouldn't bother to do it and Jim
Watson's final rule is that if you don't
like to be with people who are also good
scientists who are going to challenge
you and question your ideas and question
your experiments that's what it's all
about because somehow everybody has to
arrive at the right answer and so I want
to bring this back at the very end to
women in science so why aren't there
more women in science I think you've got
the flavor that science is really very
social Jim Watson's rules all of these
are rules about how you interact with
other people so part of the problem of
there not being many women in science is
that there aren't many women in science
it's hard
to make those connections it's harder to
network it's harder to find mentors and
that's exacerbated the problem but the
problems gotten a lot better as I said
you've seen two women science professors
at least already here today so what we
need to do is encourage people like you
guys to do whatever you want to do and
have fun doing it
and if you really enjoy doing science
then you should just forge on ahead and
there will be lots of people to help you
to make these discoveries and just to
prove to you that there are some women
in science
these showed up at a Halloween party we
had a couple of years ago they're all
graduate students and each one of them
is a different snip they're obviously
the splice girls and you can see they're
connected by axons
there's also introns in there that
you're not seeing in the picture so
that's what I have to say and maybe
people will come up and do the
demonstration maybe there'll be
questions